[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON TITUS: Hi, everyone.
It is so great to be back at
Shoreline again this year.
We want to give you the
tools to make it easy
for you to solve every day
problem in simple and powerful
ways as well as create entirely
new products using technologies
like machine learning and VR
and voice enabled interaction.
BRAD ADAMS: Your apps are now
available to Google Assistant
users across Android
and the iPhone.
You will be able to build apps
for entirely new assistive use
cases.
STEPHANIE SAAD
CUTHBERSTON: Today, we're
making Kotlin an officially
supported language in Android.
ELLIE POWERS: We are
opening up Android Instant
Apps to all Android developers.
This means anyone can now build
and publish an instant app.
FEI-FEI LI: AI is transforming
everything Google does.
And as we speak, we're
continuing the evolution
by bringing new, high level
APIs in TensorFlow 1.2.
TAL OPPENHEIMER: The
modern mobile web also
allows developers to build
deep, rich mobile experiences
with something that we
call Progressive Web Apps.
BEN GALBRAITH: We want Firebase
to be the best place for you
to start your next step.
Freeing your energies to focus
on making your app awesome,
which is where you should
be spending all your time.
JASON TITUS: Let's build
great things together.
Thank you, and have fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]